hey hey doing this is brian johnson how  much reigning kings this is one of the  most excellent excellent in Birken what  was that you could ever be look at i  look forward to saying new year hi I'm  Katie Johnson you may have heard  painting Keane's the uk's largest  christian business network and guess  what we are coming to London here at the  chelsea football blood you should come  to come trading kings there's great  people great training this is a great  place to meet with other people like  mine it with business minds you know we  need a kingdom mine but we also need a  business line and you should be here so  don't stay in bed next time get here